[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
in allen guten Abend wenn sieben Meter
hohe Wellen über eine Stadt
hineinbrechen ist das immer ein Unglück
es wird fast zwangsläufig zur
Katastrophe in einem Land in dem
bewaffnete Gruppen um einflussringen und
zwei Regierungen um die Macht schon vor
der Überschwemmung war die Infrastruktur
in Libyen ein Problem Dämme und Brücken
marode schon vor der Überschwemmung hat
die Hafenstadt Dana viel erlitten alles
kein Vergleich mit der Situation jetzt
in der sie verzweifelt versuchen der
nicht mehr fassbaren Zahl von Toten Herz
zu werden und die Überlebenden am Leben
zu halten danach hatte mal 100.000
Einwohner der Bürgermeister hält jetzt
allein in seiner Stadt 20.000 tote für
möglich goldener Teil berichtet
ob die Stadt Derna jemals wieder zum
Leben kommt ist ungewiss jetzt ist sie
nur ein riesiges Grab
ein Helfer hält fest wie die Fluten
ganze Familienhäuser wegsprengten nicht
sei mir übrig kein Stein kein Fundament
da sind Leichen inmitten der Bäume wir
können das nicht so lassen wir sägen die
Äste ab um sie zu werden sagte
aber die Toten sind immer schwerer zu
finden sie liegen im Wasser oder unter
Geröll spezielle Bergungskräfte werden
gebraucht es gebe kaum welche vor Ort
sagen Augenzeugen
das ägyptische Militär hat Hubschrauber
geschickt Soldaten suchen das Meer nach
Leichen ab
ein Großvater umarmt seinen Sohn er
trauert um seinen Engel
der Bürgermeister der Stadt befürchtet
18 bis 20.000 Tote
ich habe sieben acht Angehörige verloren
aber es gibt ganze Familien die umkamen
ganze Gebäude stürzten ein und fielen
auf Sie
augenzeugen berichten die Hilfsmaßnahmen
sein chaotisch und unkoordiniert viele
Familien hätten auch vergangene Nacht
kein Wasser keine Nahrungsmittel gehabt
das Militär hat die Stadt abgesperrt und
Checkpoints eingerichtet unabhängige
Medien heißt es sollen dort nur noch
unter Aufsicht eines aufpasses der
Regierung arbeiten dürfen
auf der Straße ins Katastrophengebiet
Einwohner aus Werner die ihre Ziegen ins
Auto gepackt haben und freiwillige
Wasser und Nahrungsmittel verteilen oder
transportieren der Westen steht dem
Osten bei es ist ihnen egal dass ihre
Machthaber verfeindet sind
wir helfen einfach mit dem was wir haben
weil die in Katastrophengebiet gar nicht
haben
aus Deutschland erreichten heute die
ersten Hilfsgüter Libyen das Technische
Hilfswerk schickte Generatoren Zelte
Wasserfilter und Betten
die parallelregierungen in Libyen
scheinen Bereiter als sonst zu
kooperieren aber selbst in diese
Tragödie besteht wenig Hoffnung dass die
nationale Trauer in politischen
Stillstand auflöst der das Land gefangen
hält
Michael Ohnmacht ist der deutsche
Botschafter in Libyen genannter
Botschafter
guten Abend wir erreichen Sie jetzt auf
dem Flughafen von Bengasi also etwa vier
Stunden vom Katastrophengebiet entfernt
aktuell wo sie Hilfsgüter erwarten wie
läuft denn die deutsche Hilfe
sind bereits angekommen
das ist alles sehr schnell ausgeladen
worden
jetzt ist natürlich das Problem sobald
sie Hilfe ja sobald die Hilfe angekommen
ist es natürlich das Problem dass man
sie auch tatsächlich in das
Katastrophengebiet bringen kann wie
optimistisch sind Sie dass das jetzt
schnell gelingt
weil es natürlich immer relativ wir
müssen sehen wir sind hier in einer auch
für dieses Land Libyen komplett
außergewöhnlichen Situation die
natürlich immer überfordernd ist so wie
sie ist aber ich hoffe das ist jetzt
schnell gelingt wieder als Deutsche
Botschaft für den Kontakt mit allen
Autoritäten die wir hier haben und
deshalb glaube ich dass das sehr gut
funktioniert aber wir können nicht jeder
einzelne Möglichkeiten und wir kommen
selber noch nichts nachher nach das
werden wir sicher versuchen aber ist
eigentlich Katastrophe gekommen ja auch
noch nicht aber die hilft wieder kommen
dorthin und das sind schon andere dort
sie erleben Sie denn die Arbeit der
Behörden vor Ort viele Menschen die wir
sprechen können dort vor Ort die die
sagen dass Ihnen aktuell praktisch
niemand wirklich hilft man hört Ärzte
die Flehen geradezu Unterstützung um mit
der großen Zahl an Leichen umgehen zu
können
das Ausmaß der Katastrophe überfordert
komplett alle Behörden wir erleben hier
allerdings ein durchaus positiven
schwierig also libyen hat ja zwei
Regierungen und im Osten keine andere
Regierung als die investieren auch das
Geld bringt aber ich sehe hier doch
einen guten Spirit zwischen beiden aber
die Probleme sind natürlich sehr stark
logistischer Natur und diese Existenz
von verschiedenen und Autorität macht
die Sache nicht gleich da aber das
Hauptproblem ist einfach logistischer
Natur und ihr Hausmeister Katastrophe
gerade in der Nacht
verstehe ich sie richtig sie haben sogar
die Hoffnung dass diese Katastrophe
möglicherweise die verfeindeten Gruppen
zusammenbringen könnte in Libyen
also ich habe gerade mit einem Minister
der der hiesigen ostregierung gesprochen
die wir nicht als solche sehen und hier
ist auf jeden Fall zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt das Wohl der Menschen und die
nationale Einheit wird als vorrangig
betrachtet und wir haben nichts
positivitäten ich bin ja sonst tausend
Kilometer weg von hier mit großen
solarität auch im Westen wie wir ihn
erlebt und natürlich müssen sich auch
Politiker diesen diesen Forderungen
stellen dass das jetzt nicht einmalig
ist also ersten
Bevölkerung kommen aber es muss auch
danach sichergestellt sein dass es eben
auch politische Fortschritte geben kann
90 ich hoffe dass die Lektion gelernt
wird weil es ist auch das ist Resultat
einer Naturkatastrophe aber man könnte
sicherlich noch besser reagieren wenn
man eben nicht diese politischen
Schwierigkeiten in diesem Land hätte wie
gesagt
Auseinandersetzung oder sowas aber wir
haben einen ein Land das eben durch
diese politische Verwaltung Respekt ist
und das gute Ideen ändert jetzt sagt die
UNO allerdings heute hätte es Warnungen
gegeben dann wäre die Mehrzahl der Toten
vermeidbar gewesen ist es am Ende dann
also nicht nur die Naturgewalt sondern
vor allem auch die politische Lage die
verantwortlich ist für diese Katastrophe
gerade eben auch die korrupten
Regierungen in der besonders betroffenen
Stadt soll es eine Ausgangssperre
gegeben haben obwohl die Menschen ja
gerade hätten fliehen müssen
also ich kann diese Meldung über die
Ausgangssperre nicht selbst wenn es
wahrscheinlich Spannungen gegeben hätte
ich bin kein Spezialist über Meterologie
aber bei starkregend hätte man erstmal
gesagt dass die Leute zu Hause bleiben
oder in höhere Gegenden gehen nur der
Dammbruch also dieser doppelte
dampfbruch der passiert ist natürlich
lag es daran dass der dann auch nicht
gewartet war wie er hätte sein müssen
aber das kam extrem überraschend und in
einer so kurzen Zeit dass man
wahrscheinlich selbst versuchen
ich bin wie gesagt kein Meteorologe und
es kommt von der under theologie-agentur
aber durchaus hier haben wir sind wir
sehr Meinung man
kann hier nicht es bringt jetzt nichts
Verantwortung auf auf einzelne Träger
zuzuschieben sondern wichtig ist jetzt
mit positiven Geist zusammen zu arbeiten
da Botschafter sie klingen vorsichtig
hoffnungsvoll was so eine Zusammenarbeit
über die Grenzen hinweg in Libyen in der
Zukunft angeht jetzt gibt es aber auch
Experten die sagen seit Jahren schon da
schlagen die verschiedenen Milizen die
verschiedenen Konfliktparteien auch aus
Krisen Profit für sich das Ganze ist
natürlich hoch gerade zynisch die Frage
ist ist das auch jetzt zu erwarten also
ist es am Ende die ganze Hilfe am Ende
etwas was der Korruption nur zuträglich
ist
das Risiko besteht immer ich hoffe nicht
ich glaube nicht und ich sehe deine
Änderungen denken ich hoffe dass diese
Änderungen denken anhält und das
wirklich alle die nötigen Lektionen
daraus lernen das ist eine Hoffnung man
kann noch solche Hoffnungen auf
enttäuscht worden aber das ist auch die
Welt die Botschaft die ich an alle
politischen entscheidungssträger die ja
durchaus zugänglich sind die zuhören
geben werde und es muss auch eine
Botschaft sein die von der gesamten
internationalgemeinschaft kommt und wir
können wir müssen als internationale
Gemeinschaft da auch mit einer Stimme
reden und dann sind wir überzeugender
die Botschaft des deutschen Botschafters
in Libyen direkt vom Flugfeld in Bengasi
er Ohnmacht herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch heute Abend
vielen Dank
das Gespräch haben wir aus technischen
Gründen vor dieser Sendung aufgezeichnet
und wir bitten die nicht ganz perfekte
Bild und Tonqualität zu entschuldigen
unser nächstes Thema ein Fünftel mehr
illegale Einreisen in die EU in diesem
Jahr bisher als in den ersten acht
Monaten des Vorjahres und die höchste
Zahl seit 2016 das sind heute die
vorläufigen Berechnungen des
europäischen Grenzschutzes das Thema ist
längst angekommen als große
Herausforderung in den Städten und
Gemeinden wo sie händeringend nach
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten suchen
angekommen in der Politik wo die Frage
nach der richtigen Reaktion auf
Migration und Flüchtlingsbewegungen
Wahlkämpfe bestimmt angekommen auch an
den Grenzen gerade im Osten Deutschlands
wo Landespolitiker deutlich mehr
Kontrollen fordern Cornelia schimans und
Franziska wunderlich waren mit der
Polizei unterwegs an Sachsens Grenze zu
Polen
ein Kleinbus 7,2 Quadratmeter ohne
Fenster in diesem Auto wurden 49
türkische und syrische Menschen
geschleust darunter 20 Kinder 12 Stunden
Fahrt ohne Essen ohne Trinken dann zieht
die Polizei den Transporter im Landkreis
Görlitz aus dem Verkehr selbst
hartgesottene Beamte sind geschockt
wir fanden die Person teils dehydriert
vor
sie waren geschwächt die Kollegen mit
vor Ort haben ihre persönlichen
Wasservorräte die die dabei hatten erst
einmal die Migranten gegeben die Polizei
hat ihre Präsenz entlang der sächsischen
Grenzen verstärkt aus ganz Sachsen wird
die Bereitschaftspolizei zu mobilen
Grenzkontrollen abgeordnet
wir unterstützen vorrangig die
Bundespolizei bei ihren Aufgaben
sprich mobile Kontrollen und verstärken
dadurch auch die Präsenz und erhöhen
auch den Druck auf die mutmaßigen
Schleuser das diese quasi hier auf gut
deutsch keine Lust mehr haben die
Örtlichkeiten zu nutzen im ersten
Halbjahr 2023 wurden allein im
Bundespolizei Bezirk Pirna und 13.500
illegal eingereiste aufgegriffen und 400
Schleuser festgenommen für die Menschen
die direkt an der Grenze wohnen Alltag
fast täglich
zu suchen die Leute die haben da drin zu
bleiben
sind an der Belastungsgrenze
Unterbringung und vor allem Integration
können kaum noch geleistet werden klagt
der Görlitzer Landrat
und deswegen habe ich mich ja auch
mehrfach mittlerweile an den Bund
gewandt und die Reaktion bleibt aus und
auch das ist ja ein Zeichen dass man uns
nicht ernst genug nimmt und das ist ein
Vorwurf den ich auch wiederum an den
Bund richten muss laut Maja sei die
Stimmung in der Bevölkerung gekippt
profitieren würden die politischen
Ränder in Görlitz beruft die AFD eine
sonderstadtratssitzung ein Thema
illegale Migration es ist das Thema dass
die Gemüter in der Region erhitzt wir
können die
illegale Einwanderung nur dadurch
stoppen indem wir Grenzkontrollen
durchführen und es muss die
Zurückweisung geben denn Polen ist ein
sicheres Land obwohl müssen sehr schönes
Land ich weiß nicht warum die alle
hierher wollen also erst Polen kommt ist
nicht mehr verfolgt hat kein Fluchtgrund
mehr doch zum einen will Polen die
geflüchteten nicht zurück zum anderen
hat jeder der am Asyl bittet nach
deutschem Recht auch den Anspruch auf
ein Prüfer fahren Sachsens Innenminister
drängt ebenfalls auf stationäre
Grenzkontrollen wie in Bayern und auf
eine Umsetzung der eu-beschl zum
besseren Schutz der EU-Außengrenzen da
müsste das hauptbetroffene Land von
dieser Migrationssituation Deutschland
längst in einer treiberrolle sein dass
diese Beschlüsse umgesetzt werden da
erlebe ich Deutschland nicht es gibt
aus meiner Sicht grund genug für die
Regierung in Berlin eine asylwende
herbeizuführen die Wut in Ländern und
Kommunen wird größer die Forderungen an
den Bund lauter im Wissen darum dass die
Zahl illegaler Grenzübertritte im Herbst
noch ansteigen wird
und im heute-
so jetzt eine Abstimmung in Thüringen
heute die für Aufsehen sorgt und zwar
bundesweit damit beginnst du den ersten
Nachrichtenüberblick Hannah die CDU im
Thüringer Landtag hat heute mit den
Stimmen von AFD FDP und einigen
fraktionslosen eine Senkung der
Grunderwerbsteuer durchgesetzt die
rot-rot-grüne Minderheitsregierung
votierte dagegen der Schritt wurde von
der Regierungskoalition scharf
kritisiert die CDU gebe der AFD dadurch
erstmals einen Einfluss auf den
Landeshaushalt der Vorgang zeigt ein
Jahr vor den Landtagswahlen in Thüringen
die schwierigen Mehrheitsverhältnisse im
Landtag die AFD wird in Thüringen vom
Verfassungsschutz als erwiesen
rechtsextrem eingestuft
wegen der Ankunft Tausender geflüchteter
hat die italienische
mittelmeerinsellampedusa den Notstand
ausgerufen seit Wochen beginnen
erreichten laut Behörden mehr als 8.000
Bootsflüchtlinge die Insel teilweise kam
es zu chaotischen Szenen das
Aufnahmelager auf Lampedusa ist komplett
überlastet denn eigentlich ist es nur
für etwa 400 Menschen ausgelegt nun
werden geflüchtete aus Festland gebracht
labbadosa liegt rund 190 km vor der
Küste Tunesiens
die Lage in Marokko bleibt sechs Tage
nach dem schweren Erdbeben weiter
angespannt das Deutsche Rote Kreuz
musste heute einen geplanten Hilfsflug
in das Land Absagen neue Vorschriften
würden die Lieferung unmöglich machen
erklärte dass DRK immer noch fehlt in
den entlegeneren Dörfern das Nötigste
marokkanische Regierung steht
unterwachsenden Druck mehr
internationale Hilfe anzunehmen laut
Innenministerium wurden bisher
2946 Todesopfer gezählt die Chance noch
Überlebende zu finden ist inzwischen
verschwindend
der Sohn von US-Präsident Joe Biden ist
wegen eines Verstoßes gegen
waffenrechtliche Vorgaben angeklagt
worden Handarbeiten wird vorgeworfen bei
einem Waffenkauf vor mehreren Jahren
seine Drogenabhängigkeit verschwiegen
und falsche Angaben gemacht zu haben
zuvor war ein Deal zwischen dem
53-Jährigen und der zuständigen
Staatsanwaltschaft geplatzt
es war im letzten Jahr bereits im Grunde
ein Offenbarungseid für ein reiches
Industrieland
medikamentenmangel und Lieferengpässe
Eltern in Deutschland verzweifelt auf
der Suche nach Arznei für ihre kranken
Kinder es gibt ÄrztInnen und Apotheker
die sagen für dieses Jahr eine noch
schlimmere Situation voraus es Fehler
Antibiotika Schmerz und Fieber Säften
schon jetzt und die wirkliche
Infektionszeit hat ja noch gar nicht
begonnen was heute begann ist ein
Krisengipfel beim Gesundheitsminister
der versprochen hatte die Lage in den
Griff zu bekommen ob das gelingt mit
einem lauterbachschen sofort Plan ist
allerdings offen sein Appell heute
Eltern sollten keine Kinder Medikamente
Hamstern wirkt nicht unbedingt so als
sei alles unter Kontrolle morgen mit mir
kindernotaufnahme der Medizinischen
Hochschule Hannover Christine Happle
macht die Erfahrung ständig ein
bestimmtes Medikament ist für Ihre
kleinen Patienten nicht verfügbar nahezu
täglich müssen Sie hier umdisponieren
jonglieren vertrösten kein einfacher Job
insbesondere die letzte Herbst
Wintersaison mit der Zunahme der
Infektionen im kindes- und Jugendalter
haben uns aber gezeigt dass wir trotz
wieder Aufnahme der Lieferketten in
bedingten Maßen mit dem Rücken zur Wand
stehen und viele Infektionen nicht mehr
behandelt werden können und viele
Antibiotika und auch andere Medikamente
für unsere Patienten auch unsere
schwerkranken Patientinnen nicht mehr zu
erhalten sind rund 400 Medikamente
stehen auf einer Dringlichkeitsliste des
Gesundheitsministeriums darunter auch
viele Kinder Arzneimittel die
priorisiert beschafft werden sollen eine
Herausforderung für den Großhandel nach
intensiver Prüfung der
Mitgliedsunternehmen können wir sagen
dass lediglich 10% dieser
halt Arzneimittel in einer Tiefe von
vier Wochen zur Verfügung gestellt
werden kann 25 Prozent also etwa 100
Arzneimittel sind gar nicht lieferbar
derzeit eine Ursache die
wirkstoffproduktion findet weitgehend im
Ausland statt nach einer Studie des
Branchenverbandes pro Generika zu mehr
als 60 Prozent in China und Indien in
den letzten 20 Jahren haben wir
zunehmend Lieferketten verengt und und
gerade bei den Generika also den
patentfreien Arzneimitteln ist nur noch
ein einziger Hersteller oft in der Lage
die Rabattverträge zu erfüllen und wenn
dann diese Fabrik ausfällt dann haben
wir sofort ein Versorgungsengpass wir
müssen also gucken dass wir die
Lieferketten breite aufstellen und
zunehmen sollten uns auch überlegen ob
wir uns geopolitisch nicht zu sehr
abhängig gemacht haben von Indien und
China die Situation aus dem letzten
Winter soll sich nicht wiederholen als
Eltern verzweifelt nach Medikamenten
suchten Apotheken verzweifelt andere
Apotheken anriefen eine
medikamentenbeschaffungskrise wohl
hausgemacht
wir hören aus anderen Ländern hören wir
das ist der reibungslos warum habt ihr
solche Probleme wir können alles liefern
wir kriegen alles das heißt da müssen
wir schauen was wir da machen können um
dort nicht das Schlusslicht zu sein per
Gesetz will Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach gegen Steuern unter anderem
Anreize setzen für mehr inländische
Produktionen nach dem Gipfel heute mit
Vertretern von Apotheken Ärzten und
Herstellern die positive Nachricht die
Lage scheint stabil es werden mehr
Medikamente produziert doch krisenfrei
durch den Winter das geht nur mit einem
mahnenden Appell an alle
bitte keine Hamsterkäufe Eltern die
fiebersäfte und Antibiotika benötigen
müssen Sie auch zuverlässig bekommen
können und es kann durch stattfinden
wenn nicht gehortet wird doch wird das
ausreichen kurzfristig schon so
Lauterbachs Hoffnung langfristig hilft
die dauerhafte Verlagerung der
medikamentenproduktion nach Deutschland
ihre Reaktion zu Hause auf die nächste
Nachricht die heute bei uns dürfte sehr
entscheidend davon abhängen ob sie
gerade Geld anlegen wollen oder sich
Geld leihen müssen Europas Zentralbank
hat es nämlich wieder getan zum 10 Mal
in Folge den Leitzins erhöht um weitere
0,25 Punkte auf
4,5%. so hoch war der Zins zu dem sich
Banken frisches Geld bei der Zentralbank
besorgen können zuletzt vor 22 Jahren
Ergebnis klar Hörer Erträge für Sparer
höhere Kosten für Kreditnehmer aber eben
nicht nur das diese Entscheidung aus dem
EZB Tower in Frankfurt am Main hat auch
Folgen für die schwächelnde Wirtschaft
insgesamt Stefan
die Inflation hoch das Wachstum niedrig
eine toxische Mischung für jede
Wirtschaft das weiß auch die
ezb-präsidentin die Spannung heute groß
ob die EZB auf die Bremse tritt sie tut
es nicht mit dem zehnten Schritt in
Folge steigt der Leitzins auf 4,5%
Punkte
die Inflation geht weiter zurück wird
aber voraussichtlich noch zu lange zu
hoch bleiben wir sind entschlossen dafür
zu sorgen dass die Inflation zeitnah zu
unserem mittelfristigen Ziel von 2%
zurückkehrt
noch höhere Zinsen dabei haben sich
Kredite und Investitionen in den letzten
Monaten schon so verteuert sagt theodoro
Krapp mit seinem Unternehmen entwickelt
der Photovoltaikanlagen von kleinen für
Einfamilienhäuser bis zu großen für
Gewerbe und Solarparks die Branche boomt
sie könnten viel mehr installieren aber
die hohen Zinsen verhindern manches
Projekt die Nachfrage ist da und wir
könnten schneller wachsen als was wir
jetzt tun weil die Finanzierungskosten
sind momentan uns zu hoch für
Großprojekte müssen die müssen wir ja
verschieben weil das in sechste Bereich
ist für kleinere Projekte müssen wir im
Lager eben das Material halten die
Zinsen sind zu einer Belastung geworden
in teilende Wirtschaft das zeigt sich in
der Industrie und vor allem auf dem Bau
wo rein Weise Aufträge wegen gestiegener
Kosten und Verunsicherung wegbrechen
gerade in Deutschland dem Kraftwerk
Europas ist die Lage schwierig
die Inflationsrate ist hierzulande mit
6,4% deutlich höher als in den anderen
großen Volkswirtschaften der Eurozone
gleichzeitig schrumpft die deutsche
Wirtschaft während sie in den anderen
Ländern noch zulegen kann
wirtschaftlich konjunkturell ist vieles
Haus gemacht und haben wir jetzt den
Preis für 10 Jahre zu wenig Investition
und hat auch ein wirtschaftliches
Geschäftsmodell was zu lange halten nur
ausgerichtet war auf billige Energie und
Exporte und das bröckelt jetzt langsam
weg auch wenn die EZB nur der
Preisstabilität verpflichtet ist sie
kann die konjunkturelle Entwicklung
nicht außer Acht lassen mit dem heutigen
Tag scheint das Ende der Zinserhöhungen
gekommen EZB hat ja immer eine
zwitterfunktion auf der einen Seite muss
die Inflation bekämpfen aber sie muss
natürlich auf die Konjunktur schauen im
Augenblick ja nicht zum besten gestellt
ist und da hat sie gesagt wie hören
heute noch mal zum letzten Mal den Zins
und dann machen wir bei nichts mehr
damit die Konjunktur langsam aber sicher
wieder durchatmen kann
viele Beobachter gehen davon aus dass im
kommenden Jahr die Zinsen schon wieder
sinken könnten das würde es theodoro
Grab und vielen anderen Unternehmen
wieder leichter machen
ja da gucken wir mal wie es tatsächlich
kommt viele hatten jetzt aktuell
zunächst mal mit einer Zinspause
gerechnet Frank Bethmann ist unser
Wirtschaftsfachmann hallo Frank so ist
es jetzt nicht gekommen Hauptsache
Inflation geht runter auch wenn das für
die Konjunktur möglicherweise Gift sein
könnte ist das so das Motto der
Notenbanker naja die Notenbanker sind
vor allem eins verpflichtet nämlich der
Stabilität der Wertstabilität des Geldes
und dem müssen sie sozusagen folgen und
wir haben es eben im Bericht schon
gesehen die Inflation in Deutschland
immer noch bei 6,4 % in der Eurozone bei
5,13%. da ist also noch ordentlich Druck
auf dem Kessel um das mal so zu sagen ja
und ist das für Deutschland jetzt eine
gute oder eine schlechte Entscheidung
mal ganz allgemein gesprochen ist eine
hohe Inflation mit das unsozialste was
es überhaupt gibt ist klar wer ein
geringes Einkommen hat und dann
Lebensmittel werden teuer die Heizung
der Strom der wird sich irgendwann
entscheiden müssen was kann ich mir
davon noch leisten oder nicht die
Vermögen darin sagen dann ein Mensch
mein Lieblingskäse schon wieder teurer
geworden
ärgert sich aber nimmt es dann
vielleicht mit also das sind so die
Unterschiede insofern ja für Deutschland
ist es gut aber wir haben es den Beitrag
auch schon gesehen es gibt natürlich
ganz viel wie die Bauwirtschaft und so
weiter und so fort die heute sagen ein
wahnsinnig schlechter Tag reden wir über
die Auswirkungen auf die Verbraucher
noch bitte viele Banken geben ja auch
aktuell in dieser Situation immer noch
super unfassbar mickrige Zinsen setzen
offenbar darauf wenn überhaupt die
Zinsen setzen offenbar darauf dass es
niemand merkt hat das denn jetzt ein
Ende mit dem heutigen Tag nee in
Automatismus gibt es nicht es kann immer
noch jede Bank frei entscheiden wie viel
Zinsen sie ihren Kunden gibt und den
Kunden kann man eigentlich nur zu rufen
also wenn die Hausbank nichts macht dann
musst du was machen es gibt auf
Tagesgeld von drei Prozent plus X und
bis zu einer gewissen Anlage Höhe sind
die Einlagen auch komplett gesichert
also die Banken spielen da schon ein
bisschen mit der Bequemlichkeit ihre
kurz nach vorne bitte fragt die
Multimillionen Dollar Frage wie geht es
jetzt weiter runter wohl erstmal
zumindest nicht mit den Zinsen aber noch
weiter höher Fragezeichen also es war
heute im EZB-Rat es ist viel diskutiert
worden aber eins sagte Christine lagard
Zinsen runter war heute überhaupt kein
Thema ich rechne tatsächlich damit dass
es jetzt zu dieser Zinspause kommt mit
der heute schon viele gerechnet haben
womöglich sogar über das Jahr hinaus
denn das war zwischen den Zeilen
deutlich zu hören dieses Zinsniveau soll
es jetzt vielleicht erstmal sein ja du
sollst jetzt erstmal richten ob es dann
im nächsten Jahr wieder runter geht kann
heute noch niemand sagen
Notenbanker lassen sich immer das
Hintertürchen offen Frau lagarat hat
heute dann auch noch mal gesagt also ob
das jetzt schon der zinsgipfel war das
können Sie heute noch nicht sagen okay
Frank Wittmann herzlichen Dank für diese
interessante Analyse heute Abend wieder
so und wir bleiben noch in der
Wirtschaft bzw bei der Wirtschaft mit
Diana jetzt und schauen auf die Lage bei
Volkswagen der Konzern baut Stellen in
seiner e-auto-fabrik im sächsischen
Zwickau ab 269 befristete Verträge die
bald auslaufen würden nicht verlängert
die Gewerkschaft IG Metall kritisierte
die Entscheidung scharf als Grund nannte
das Unternehmen die aktuelle
Marktsituationen angesichts hoher
Inflation und zurückgehender Kaufprämien
hielten sich die Kunden zurück der
Konzern sei weiterhin von E-Mobilität
überzeugt dass zwickauer-werk stehe
nicht zur Disposition sagte ein Sprecher
russland hat in der Nacht laut Kiew
erneut mehrere Regionen in der Ukraine
angegriffen dabei sei ein sechsjähriger
Junge in der Region getötet worden zudem
gab es Verletzte am Abend kündigte ein
ukrainischer Gouverneur an das Familien
in dem Gebiet wegen des ständigen
feindlichen Beschusses Zwangs evakuiert
werden sollen auf der von Russland
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten Krim kam
es unterdessen offenbar zu schweren
Explosionen gefilmt von Anwohnern laut
dem ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
soll ein russisches Flugabwehrsystem
getroffen worden sein
mit einer feierlichen Zeremonie haben
Berlin und Kiew heute eine
Städtepartnerschaft geschlossen im Roten
Rathaus unterzeichneten Kiews
Bürgermeister Klitschko und berlins
Regierender Bürgermeister Wegner dazu
eine gemeinsame Erklärung mit Blick auf
den russischen Angriffskrieg grobwegner
hervor dass Berlin fest an der Seite der
Ukraine stehe meine Damen und Herren
mehr dazu gleich im ZDF wir empfehlen
gleich nach uns die Kollegin Maybrit
Illner und ihr Thema Ukraine unter
Zeitdruck kleine Erfolge große Ungeduld
Fragezeichen zu Gast unter anderem die
stellvertretende ukraineische
Verteidigungsministerin und uns alle
hier von heute journal gibt's morgen
wieder und gegen 0:30 Uhr meldet sich
dann hier Christopher Wehrmann mit
unserem heute journal Update ein
angenehmer
[Musik]
guten Abend heute lagen die
Höchsttemperaturen in Deutschland
zwischen 18 und 25 Grad aber über das
Wochenende am Montag auch noch im Osten
kratzen wir noch mal an der 30 Grad
Marke das hängt zusammen mit Tiefs im
Westen die befördern nämlich zusammen
mit dem hoch das langsam weiter nach
Osten zieht wärmere Luft aus Südwesten
in unsere Richtung schon morgen erwarten
uns Temperaturen in Frankreich von 25
bis 30 Grad auch am Mittelmeer liegen
die Temperaturen zwischen 25 und 35 Grad
das mittelme selbst ist sogar noch
wärmer hier vor Israel liegen die
Wassertemperaturen bei 29 Grad vor
Tunesien sind es 27 Grad der Atlantik
bei den Kanarischen Inseln hat eine
Wassertemperatur von 26 Grad ganz anders
sehen unsere Nachttemperaturen aus in
der Lüneburger Heide sinken die Werte
bis auf 4 Grad milder bleibt die Nacht
an den Küsten von Nord und Ostsee und
auch am Oberrhein dazu ist diese Nacht
meist klar
befindet sich wieder Nebel es gibt nur
wenige Wolkenfelder und wenn sich der
Nebel morgen über Tag dann erstmal
aufgelöst hat dann strahlt wieder die
Sonne es gibt nur wenige Wolken
allerdings können sich dann am späten
Nachmittag und Abend aus den Alpen
heraus also im Allgäu oder auch im
Bodensee durchaus mal Gewitter bilden
die Temperaturen liegen zwischen 21 und
28 Grad und nach einem
spätsommerwochenende beenden dann am
Montag von Westen Gewitter diese
Spätsommer Episode guten Abend